derrière la crise sanitaire en afrique
une crise alimentaire
le nombre de personnes infectées
pourraient doubler selon le programme
alimentaire mondial si des mesures ne
sont pas prises rapidement prime
hospital des scènes de cohue lors de la
distribution des aides alimentaires en
plein coeur de la capitale kényane des
habitants d'un bidonville de nairobi
bousculé et piétinées alors qu'une crise
probablement plus graves que le
coronavirus est en train de gagner le
continent africain
c'est de la pénurie alimentaire comme
vous pouvez le voir des gens sont battus
certains ont amené leurs enfants ils
sont blessés
ce n'est pas juste nous ne recevons pas
de nourriture à kibera ceci n'est qu'un
moyen de contacter directement le virus
nous ne faisons rien pour nous protéger
contre le virus
mourir de faim au contracté la maladie
un vrai dilemme auquel fait face
actuellement l'afrique l'onu redoute que
la pandémie de coronavirus ne soit un
facteur aggravant de la pénurie
alimentaire
la fermeture des marchés la récession
économique devrait entraîner une perte
de revenus importante pour les
travailleurs pauvres
selon le directeur du programme
alimentaire mondial des nations unies
le pea m 135 millions de personnes
supplémentaires sont confrontés à
différents niveaux de crise de la faim
ou pire cela signifie que 135 millions
de personnes sur terre sont au bord de
la famine
mais maintenant l'analyse du programme
alimentaire mondial montre également
qu'en raison du coronavirus 130 millions
d'autres personnes pourraient être
poussés au bord de la famine d'ici la
fin de 2020
cela représente un total de 265 millions
de personnes pour venir en aide aux plus
démunis
le programme alimentaire mondial des
nations unies tentent de fournir une
aide médicale et humanitaire au pays
durement touché par la crise les
organismes humanitaires redoutent que
l'insécurité alimentaire s'aggrave dans
plusieurs pays et territoires également
bouleversé par les conflits